guaranteed you're seconding come on at
vaynermedia today sure I would say it's
claude silver she's our chief heart
officer I think when you're when you
have 700 employees and you're selling
people that's the asset and so when you
were talking about culture I was
laughing because you're like it's
awesome I'm like I wonder what the other
5000 people think right because culture
is a one-person thing and so when I
think about culture I'm sure you agree
like I I know that we're trying so so
hard way way more than norm but I don't
know what it means to all 700 we asked
and we're counter punchers we don't push
it we respond to it and so at Vayner
it's claude silver as cheap hard officer
then I would say it's James Rossini
who's our chief operating officer Manor
Media and so I watched you grow that
from 12 people yep that's right and I
kind of understood some of the pain
what's been the hardest thing but I
actually what I really want to say is
you've operated smaller businesses
what's it like to actually run what does
I mean we walk into the new space you're
blown away what does it like to operate
so far so good
I mean you know the the hardest part and
have what it feels like is the same
answer which is how do you get buy-in at
scale it's a lot easier to get 30 people
to buy into you and your vision then it
is 500 and 700 that's fun for me to see
four or five of them in here and they're
all in different parts of their career
at Vayner right now and different
challenges or opportunities I've always
thought about that
I literally reverse engineer every
single person I have context of how they
came from the conversations we've had
who their mentors were before what they
thought Emily's mom thought that we were
some mafioso thing like like you know I
know who's Sams Sams mentor was I
understand where Lisa worked in a
traditional agency for 14 years I know
that Garrett we went to the same school
as my children like I know [ __ ] like I
am the head of HR , CEO and so always
Wine Library vaynermedia and everything
I do forever
it's only a people game everything else
continues to get commoditized
by technology this is a human thing we
are humans we are the ultimate species
we've won it's us and we are the game
and so yes I have thought about that I
think the reason we built one of the
fastest growing agencies ever is because
of that part of it and the biggest
challenge is getting by in knowing that
knowing that a 200 people there are so
many people that didn't believe me that
thought oh tomorrow I'm gonna do
something bad or I'm doing this because
I want to buy the Jets and I don't care
about them or whatever it may be and
it's been a lot of fun for me because
now we're a little further along and
everybody who's been waiting every day
that it doesn't switch it doesn't turn
it doesn't become about the money
they aren't forced to do things we keep
listening you know it's like gaining
trust right and so now we guts we are
much tighter and stronger at seven
hundred than we were at two fifty which
is usually the other way
but that's what happens when you
actually double down on it and when the
stories translate and it's not always
perfect even the people in this room
it's not clicking perfectly right this
second but you put in the effort you put
in the effort and you play it forever
game you treat them just as well on the
way out and forever and help and it's
just it's a people game yeah I've always
thought that it's really the only move
I've got